Jennifer's in Wyoming hi Jennifer
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
how are you better than I deserve
what's up Mika's had a question um I
found your book about three four days
ago I've listened to it four times now
Wow yeah I'm pretty serious about this
I'm in trouble as far as I'm been with
somebody for 11 years and we had been
married for four years you have a four
year old little boy and these past few
months I've really just looked at him
and realized how fast his life is really
going I have no savings for him I have
no savings and me and my husband are
completely separated separate in
finances and when I say separate I mean
we have separate bank accounts
the house is in his name the only thing
that we share with our name on the same
piece of paper is our car loans my truck
will be paid off next month and we've
had that loan for six years and I've
paid it myself the entire six years and
then he has a car loan that will be
older you know say I'm 31 and he's 34
going on 35 and what does he do for a
living
he's a correctional officer sergeant
what do you do for a living I'm a yield
accountant for refinery so numbers are
second nature to you yes sir and then my
I'll have my associates degree next year
either January or May depending on how
some classes land but I've worked in
accounting for many years okay where
you're sitting is not unusual at all for
someone that has taken the life path
that you all have taken it's pretty
simple you lived together without being
married for six years
and so you kept everything separate you
were roommates and and now combining
everything is not natural because you
did it the other way for six years not
six minutes six years and so you know
taught the discussion of combining
everything feels weird because you've
the other way has been determined to be
normal the problem with that is your
normal sucks because married couples who
do not handle money together have a
statistical probability of losing with
money it's almost impossible we almost
never find couples handling their money
separately who win with money because
Jesus said your treasures where your
heart is and when you come into
agreement on where your money's going
you're really discussing and agreeing
and modifying and compromising on where
your total life is going when you agree
on your spending you've agreed on your
life and when you keep your life
separate it's hard to have a high
quality relationship I brought this to
him I I completely 100% agree we have
been in actually full-blown fights the
last three days over it because he it's
almost like he's unconvincing do you do
this with me I like that I've listened
to about four times I've even started it
again today I've been listening to it
all morning and I would be his downside
of considering trying something new
that's what I can't even understand
he pretty much thinks that I'm just
trying to take his money and it's my
money you're married he doesn't own a
state of Wyoming it's not his money
you're married
it's our went to give up all of his
extra money yeah to pay off it yeah
and so sorry Bobby you have a wife and a
kid you already gave up all this
independent
that's how life works so I mean there's
no way there's no way getting around
this even if you were to divorce you get
half his dadgum stuff I mean that's how
this works in Wyoming works in most
states that way okay so that's why they
say marriage is grand divorce is 50
grand right so you get to split the
stuff up thank you if I can't get him on
board you well you've been at this for
days so let's calm down a little bit
okay let's not get all apocalyptic but
what I would say is this just you know
bribe him just say you know there's some
fun stuff on the other side of you
listening to this audio book and after
you listen to this audio book there's
some fun stuff on the other side of it
and just you know just say you know calm
down a little bit here nobody wants your
stinking money by the way the law says I
already got your stinking money just in
case you're worried about it okay and I
don't want your stinking money I want
you and me to work together as a couple
and have a wonderful marriage in a
wonderful future and a high statistical
probability of living our dreams and
giving a wonderful home to our kid and
those kinds of things if you can get him
to go to Financial Peace University
which right now you can't okay but if
you can talk him into it I'm gonna put
you on hold Kelly's gonna pick up and
she's gonna give you her contact so you
can get back to her but if you can ever
talk him into it I'll pay for it you can
go for free because there's an almost 0%
chance if he goes through that nine week
class with you that he will not convert
I'm really good at convincing you to do
this the right way
it's about all I'm good at but I'm
really good at that so there you go hang
on
Kelly I'll pick up we'll help you out